a lot of people have had the experience
of trying to Rebrand or create new
products and features under a brand and
for a lot of consumers they already know
you as something and it's really hard to
convince them you're going to do these
six other things look at the end of the
day that story is going to be written
based on the execution naming is funny
because at the end of the day names are
executed if Google was a shitty company
and didn't do well that name sucks but
because it wasn't it doesn't suck right
McDonald's is a local pub in Ireland or
a global qsr giant the execution made
the name there so I think what happens
the next five years on execution will
then tell the story about the Rebrand
but that's a lot of brand Equity to give
up